yesterday Greg Brockman the president
and co-founder of openai announced the
company's ideas about releasing the
models Beyond gpt4 in the Tweet he made
lots of points of which I found five to
be particularly telling I will cover all
of them of course and bring in the
outside evidence that reveals more but
let's start with Jeep T5 which may begin
life as GPT 4.2 Brockman said it's easy
to create a Continuum of incrementally
better AIS such as by deploying
subsequent checkpoints of a given
training run I'm going to explain that
in a moment but then he goes on this
would be very unlike our historical
approach of infrequent major model
upgrades so what he's saying is that
it's not all going to be released in one
go he describes this as a safety
opportunity so it's not like we're going
to wake up overnight and gbt5 is
deployed more like GPT 4.2 then 4.3 Etc
but how would they make incrementally
better AI eyes and what are subsequent
checkpoints of a given training run to
be clear he's not describing a different
model each time with more and more
parameters a checkpoint during a
training run of gypsy 5 would be a
snapshot of the current value of the
parameters of the model a bit like its
current understanding of the data and a
subsequent checkpoint would be its
updated parameters as it processes
either more of the data or the same data
more times kind of like someone who
rewatched a film and has a more nuanced
understanding of it first I want to
answer those people who are thinking
isn't it already trained on all of the
data on the internet how can it get
smarter now I did cover this in more
detail in my first GT5 video but the
short answer is this no we're not yet
running out of data in that video I
talked about how openai may still have
an order of magnitude more data to use
that's 10 times more data still
available and Ilya satskova the chief
scientist of openai put it like this
saying the data situation looks good are
you running out of reasoning tokens on
the internet are there enough of them
there are claims that indeed at some
point we'll run out of tokens in general
to train those models and yeah I think
this will happen one day and we'll by
the time that happens we need to have
other ways of training models without
more data but you haven't run out of
data yet there's more yeah I would say I
would say the data situation is still
quite good there's still lots to go what
is the most valuable source of data is
it Reddit Twitter books what would you
trade many other tokens of other
varieties for generally speaking you'd
like tokens which are
speaking about smarter things which are
like more interesting when he talked
about tokens which are speaking about
smarter things you can imagine the kind
of data he's talking about proprietary
data sets on mathematics science coding
they could essentially buy their way to
more data and more high quality data but
there is another key way that they're
going to get way more data and that is
from you they can use your prompts your
responses your uploaded images and
generated images to improve their
services this is honestly why I think he
said that the data situation looks good
now on another page they do admit that
you can request to opt out of having
your data used to improve their services
by filling out a form but not many
people are going to do that it does make
me wonder what it might know about
itself if it's trained on its own
conversations but before we get back to
brockman's tweet what might those
different checkpoints look like in terms
of growing intelligence here is a quick
example from Sebastian bubeck author of
the famous Sparks of age GI paper so
this is this is dpt4's unicorn okay
okay so you see you see when I
I am personally
personally concept of a unicorn and just
to be clear you know so that you really
understand visually it's clear to you
the gap between gpt4 and charge apt this
is charging's unicorn
over the month so you know we had access
uh in in September and they kept
training it and as they kept training it
I kept querying for my unicorn in TXI
okay to see whether you know what was
going to happen and this is you know
what happened okay
so it kept improving the next telling
point was this he said perhaps the most
common theme from the long history of AI
has been incorrect confident predictions
from experts there are so many that we
could pick from but let me give you two
quick examples this week there was a
report in the guardian about an
economist who saw chat GPT get a d on
his midterm exam he predicted that a
model wouldn't be able to get an A in
his exam before 2029 he said to my
surprise and no small dismay the new
version of the system Gypsy 4 got an A
scoring 73 out of 100. it still has an
ace the exam but you can see the
direction of travel but what about
predictions of say mathematics even AI
experts who are most familiar with
exponential curves are still poor at
predicting progress even though they
have their cognitive bias so here's an
example in 2021 a set of like
professional forecasters very well
familiar with exponentials we're asked
to make a set of predictions and there
was a 30 thousand dollar pop for making
the best predictions and one of the
questions was when will AI be able to
solve competition level mathematics with
greater than 80 accuracy this is the
kind of example of the questions that
are in this test set prediction from the
experts was AI will reach 52 accuracy in
four years but in reality that took
less than one year treats greater than
50 accuracy the third interesting point
from the Tweet was how he mentioned
existential risks without dismissing
them he said it's important to address
the whole spectrum of risks from present
day issues to longer term existential
ones existential by the way means
threatening the entire existence of
humanity and he talked about addressing
these risks he could have just said that
this is fear-mongering but he didn't and
that chimes in with what recent surveys
have shown among AI researchers this is
a stat that took me by surprise 50 of AI
researchers believe there's a 10 or
greater chance that humans go extinct
from our inability to control AI that
would be like if you're about to get on
a plane and 50 of the engineers who make
the plane say Well if you get on this
plane there's a 10 chance that everybody
goes down like would you get on that
plane now In fairness not every machine
learning researcher who has sent the
survey responded so we don't know quite
how representative this is but AI
alignment is a big topic and I will be
covering it more in the near future at
the end of the Tweet Brockman said that
the whole range of emotions optimism and
concern is both Justified and shared by
people within openai so even people
within openai are concerned but earlier
in the Tweet he talked about some safety
successes and he put it like this gpt4
performs much better on all of our
safety metrics than GPT 3.5 that's the
original chat GPT but what does that
even mean let me try to break it down I
believe that he's referring to this
chart from the gbc4 technical report it
says that Gypsy 4 in green displays
incorrect Behavior at a lower rate than
gbt 3.5 this is on sensitive prompts and
disallowed prompts and by the way this
is the fine tune version with human
feedback incorporated into the raw model
but what are sensitive prompts and
disallowed prompts well things like this
a disallowed prompt will be something
like how can I create a bomb a sensitive
prompt would be something like asking
for medical advice and it says that GT4
responds in accordance with their
policies 29 more often now I know some
of you won't like that but I'm doing
research for a video I hope to release
soon on how Gypsy 4 in an emergent way
can autonomously conduct scientific
research this paper was released two
days ago and I read it in full on the
day of publication it describes how
Gypsy 4 in contrast to the original
chatbt can use tools and come up with
novel compounds on the positive side
that could include anti-cancer drugs but
on the negative side it could be
chemical weapons and one of the calls to
action of the paper is on screen we
strongly believe that guard rails must
be put in place to prevent this type of
potential dual use of large language
models we call for the AI Community to
engage in prioritizing safety of these
powerful models and in particular we
call upon open AI Microsoft Google meta
deepmind anthropic and all the other
major players to push these strongest
possible efforts on the safety of their
llms so maybe that persuades some people
who think that there shouldn't be any
disallowed prompts but it does make me
reflect on this quote that Gypsy 4
performs better on all safety metrics
and the question that I'm pondering is
whether a smarter model can ever really
be safer is it not simply inherent that
something that is more smart is more
capable For Better Or ill no matter how
much feedback you give it the final
point that I found interesting from this
tweet is in the last line Rockman said
that it's a special opportunity and
obligation for us all to be alive at
this time I think he meant to say it's
an opportunity and obligation on all of
us who are alive but anyway he said that
we will have a chance to design the
future together now that's a really nice
sentiment but it does seem to go against
the trend at the moment for a few people
at the very top of these companies to be
making decisions that affect billions of
people so I do want to hear more about
what he actually means when he says that
we will have a chance to design in the
future together but for now I want to
quickly talk about timelines the guy
behind stable diffusion said something
really interesting recently he said
nobody is launching runs bigger than
Gypsy 4 for six to nine months anyway
why because it needs the new h100s that
I talked about in that video to get
scale and they take time to be installed
burnt in optimized Etc and Brockman
mentioned something that we already knew
which is that there might be a lag of
safety testing after a model is trained
and before it's released so depending on
those safety tests my personal
prediction for when GPT 4.2 let's call
it will be released would be mid 2024.
if you're watching this video in mid
2024 or later you can let me know in the
comments how I did I've talked a fair
bit about the capabilities that Gypsy 5
or 4.2 might have but to finish I want
to talk about some of the limitations or
weaknesses it might still have rather
than me speculate I want you to hear
from Ilya satskiver about one of the
possible remaining weaknesses that GPT 5
or 4.2 might have if I were to take the
premise of your question well like why
were things disappointing in terms of
the real world impact and my answer
would be reliability if somehow it ends
up being the case that you really want
them to be reliable and they ended up
not being reliable or if the reliability
or not to be harder than we expect I
really don't think that will be the case
but if I had to pick one if I had to
pick one and you tell me like hey like
why didn't things work out it would be
reliability that you still have to look
over the answers and double check
everything and that's just really puts a
damper on the economic value for those
system let me know what you think in the
comments and have a wonderful day